okay so he actually steps forward to the
fifth row but now white can push his
pawn forward right exactly yeah i mean
consequences to that now the pawn is one
square away from queenie oh
okay
this is very sneaky but you do have this
intermediate move which is just to give
a check with a knife actually promoting
into a queen there i think would have
been a big blunder it would have
actually walked into a queen versus
rookie game but where white king cannot
run away from the checks and now white
can just make a queen um maybe white has
other moves naraditsky he's so in focus
he's so deep in calculation mode that
he's putting his head down
[Laughter]
he's asking the chess gods what the
winning move is here
he can just promote to a queen i think
that's winning maybe can he just move
his knight i mean this is what i was
thinking okay move the knight because
the rook is totally dominated by
that knight
and uh can't stop the pawn promoting it
comes with check as well next week look
at naraditsky it's getting too
oh this is uh okay that's it we have a
result
it's over daniel naraditsky smiling
finally wins this game against such a
strong player liam
look at his face wow how impressed are
you with daniel here david super
impressed there's no way i could
multitask you know rocking back and
forth and playing great chess but he did
it and he takes the